if you're a policy maker at any level of
government you're probably wared about
artificial intelligence and what it
means for your work it's really hard to
keep up with the speed and the
complexity of the technology that's why
Mila and ppf have designed the program
for you we want you to understand the
technology better we want you to think
about the opportunities and risks and
lastly we want to provide you with an
overview of all the possible governance
and policy responses that are emerging
in Canada and abroad our experts will
answer all your questions and you will
have an opportunity to talk to your
colleagues who are facing exactly the
same challenges I hope to see you in
Ottawa in
Montreal